With over 100,000 condoms ordered in 2010
for the Vancouver Winter Olympics, it's obvious
- a little extra physical activity goes on
during the Games. But, does this sexual excitement
before competition influence an athlete's
performance?
Many ancient civilizations, including the
Greeks, believed that semen was divine and
contained a man's strength. Today, some athletes
hold the belief that sexual frustration, driven
by abstinence, ultimately increases aggression
- which is valuable for many sports. Testosterone,
in particular, is responsible for aggression
and sexual desire in both men and women, and
there has long been the belief that ejaculation
draws testosterone from the body. Muhammad
Ali, for example, wouldn't make love for six
weeks before a fight.
But modern science sees things differently.
In fact, many studies have shown the exact
opposite: testosterone increases after sex.
Go without for over 3 months, and testosterone
drops to levels near that of a child. So from
a biological perspective, sex may actually
increase performance, particularly in sports
where a bit of extra aggression could be the
deciding factor - like ski-cross, short track
speed skating, or of course hockey.
So what about sex tiring the body out? The
honest truth is that the average sex session
only burns about 50 calories...the equivalent
of running up a few flights of stairs. On
the contrary, studies have found that sex
the night before has no noticeable effects
on strength, power, endurance, or any other
fitness variables. Though, sex has been documented
to trigger the release of pain-blockers in
the brain. These can help modulate chronic
pain, with effects lasting upwards of 24 hours.
The biggest unknown lies in the psychological
effects, which is much harder to study, and
may actually play a bigger role in major competitions.
An athlete's best performance is achieved
with particular balance of alertness and anxiety.
Of course, staying up all night chasing sexual
escapades tips the scale against alertness
the next day. On the other hand, sex can be
a great stress release for nervous athletes.
While other personalities simply desire more
focus and concentration, in which case, a
good nights sleep is ideal.
At the end of the day, science says: it depends
how sex affects each individual. If you need
that extra kick of testosterone, then you
might just want to get your game on - a night early.
Don't forget: we have a new video out every day during the Olympics.
Can't wait? Our amazing partners at the CBC already have five of the videos up now for you to binge on.
Just head to cbc.ca/olympics/ScienceSays to watch them before anyone else.
Link in the description.
But we also want to know your questions for this special series. Use the hashtag ScienceSays and let us know your burning Olympic questions.
And subscribe for more awesome science videos!